I have the real
- here's my nose is broken in two places
and the scar here was that's where the
the white of my skull was showing
prison-break star Dominic Purcell
suffered some gruesome injuries while
shooting the Fox revival series in
Morocco the damage a broken nose and a
hundred stitches in his head that was
just one of those things where you know
I dodged a bullet
ET was exclusively with the 46 year old
actor on the vancouver set last week
where he opened up about what really
went down I hit the ground took a knee
and blood was just pouring all over me
and then my stunt guy came up to me and
I looked at him he said well here's the
thing
it's cut open and I can see your skull I
can your nose is smashed on the other
side of my face and I just set that
really calmly actually it was weird I
didn't I wasn't panicked obviously I was
in shock then I kind of thought well
maybe I'm gonna die in Morocco but no
and then after about four or five
minutes I just got up and said take me
to a hospital after being treated by a
Moroccan plastic surgeon dominic made a
speedy recovery he was back in the gym
just days later not so good bone
fragments here but you know it was just
one of those freak accidents and you
know it's one of those things
resin break returns to Fox March 2017